let me start by saying congrats on the
show I saw the first few episodes I
think it's going to be a big thank you
I'm confident what I'm saying right one
of the things that I really enjoyed is
that the show just jumps in it's like
there's no waste of time you just
immediately you're in this world and you
know it doesn't like sugarcoat you like
here's everything you need to know it's
like you just jump in talk a little bit
about that aspect of the show and the
fact that you just let's just start with
that
I mean I've I've always admired
Roberto's ability to balance exposition
and plot that just moves I think he's a
genius and he's just brilliant at that
and I think another thing that helped
too is that Roberto did the graphic
novel and he'd been living with these
characters for such a long time and had
been developing the show for such a long
time that by the time we all got on set
I felt very comfortable when Murray
lived in already usually there's there's
a bit of sort of an adjustment period
where you're finding your footing at the
beginning and I can't speak for everyone
but I just felt like we really jumped
right in really sort of armed and ready
to go characters were really really
clear page and the casting made them
even clearer when we went through the
first read-through it was just really
clear who everybody was and what they
were trying to do and then I think also
Lee who directed the first two episodes
who also directed the pilot of Riverdale
I think you know he really brought a lot
to mixing the genres together because
we're really dealing with quite a few
genres yeah so I think you know yeah
completely one of the things I was
wondering is what year does this show
take place in O so I'm specified isn't
it it's the word we use it's kind of
yeah classic you know watching in a way
yeah the codes and things like that I
mean some of those words like mm-hmm the
world
yeah just wondering yeah
yeah yeah I had I had I had read really
early iteration of the script where it
was it was stated that it was in the 60s
but I know that they changed that to
move to sort of just a timeless yeah
wrote of period for I think a little bit
more flexibility with one thing a first
time disappointed that it wasn't the 60s
and now I love the timelessness of it
like there's a scene in Episode one or
two Ambrose is just on a laptop and I
say oh I like that I like that there's
just it's that's random and I saw I like
that yeah is that the show is I like
that it's sort of in an unspecified time
because it feels like we can address
things without having to be too specific
about anything we can deal with these
sort of feminist patriarchal sort of
issues without it feeling like we have
to be digesting you know good things or
older things you know figuring out cut
its sons gives the level of oh yeah yeah
yeah one of the things how much did you
want to know about the arc of the entire
season and how much do you enjoy getting
its script by script I like to know
where I'm going but I have to say some
things have changed along the way like
things that they were going to do
they've done different things as they've
gone along I think they they throw a lot
of ideas around in the writers room all
the time about like what things that
they're going to come up with so that's
a nice quick quick
oh really we quit yet yeah I know I'm a
control freak no no I want it so well I
get it sometimes I do but then then
things for different reasons like you
said do completely change and I and then
I get set on that idea and then it
changes so I kind of like enjoy seeing
the script and don't oh this is
happening exactly so yeah I'd like to
know if my character has like some sort
of secret or something that there are
hard questions field later I'd like to
know that sort of yeah yeah whatever I'm
doing yeah but otherwise I as
I get enough time with the script before
I start actually I'm filming it like it
once I get a few days to actually sort
of digest it and work on it
I'm good with I'm good with that but if
they wanted to give me all the entire
story I wouldn't talk about working with
Miranda character arcs I have a few
quote-unquote fun questions where you
see them really fast uh what TV show
would you like to guest star on the
crown someone yeah yeah one I'm stealing
hers is there anything that you collect
no oh not really
no scripts we should start collecting
just so I'm not so for this I know I
feel like one of us food collector or
something yeah when I was little I used
to collect dolls
oh yeah what's the background photo on
your phone me and my daughter
yeah oh you know what mine's actually
really fun mine is so the day that I got
Sabrina and I just changed it the other
day because it was my dog for forever
but the day I got Sabrina Elon Musk's
well under some weird thing into the sky
and I thought the world was anything and
I was like not today what TV show have
you watched all the way through more
than once the US office probably right
the development do you have a favorite
pair of sneakers or shoes yeah yeah you
wouldn't mean the brand or the name the
shoes or no I think it's so old I think
mine is so old and rugged and I got it
from a shop in England called Marks and
Spencers it's not known for shoes
however it's from their shoes
running for X okay make a mess noble day
I just like I like slides I like
something that I can put on and then
easily yes kick off oh gosh I can't
think offhand I wear a lot of heels oh
yeah a lot of heels I have a million
others but I'm gonna stop there because
I'm what we call out of time
listen congratulations on the show you
really do you think people are really
gonna dig it
you